yeah yeah finally
it finally happened my favorite channel
my favorite channel finally did it video
on me I'm talking of course about watch
if you don't know WatchMojo that's like
you don't know Jesus WatchMojo the
greatest top ten channel of all time
with such classic title and top 10
animation if you think I've been out of
ideas WatchMojo I've done a whole new
level of out of ideas net top 10
greatest sandwiches of all time you
can't beat that you just care of top 10
celebrities who try to hide going ball
top 10 unforgettable anime alien
but now the day I prayed for has finally
come top 10 funniest PewDiePie videos
really top 10 not top 3 how did they
manage to get top 10 of that I think but
that's impossible as gallon breath
its how's it going sisters ok get it
right get it right damn it it's called
we're called sisters now sister Pfister
already complete failure come to
watchmojo.com and today we're counting
down our picks for the top 10 funniest
qtpie videos obviously a ploy to stutter
before we begin we publish new videos
every day so be sure to subscribe for
more great content well you know wait
wait wait wait wait you upload 12 videos
a day do you want to get spammed with
top 10 videos check it out number 10
reading mean comment as we all know
intense pain brings its fair share of
critics why are your headphone
pink Lal number nine what really that's
what they pick that's what they pick
funny montage three sorry funny gaming
montage flappy bird happy will y'all
nippers just went to my top popular
videos you didn't even watch my videos
you just went to most popular in selects
today what the [ __ ] god damn yo wait
what does this check out these related
PT paisa oh you [ __ ] it's not a
referral link it's a [ __ ] referral
link you sneaky [ __ ] you know
what [ __ ] this I'm gonna make my own top
10 video it might be extremely
self-absorbed self praising self loving
but that's who I am baby and if you
don't like it you could just go home
[ __ ] okay I made a list I made a list
of top my favorite PewDiePie videos if
you haven't watched it you're not a real
sister Fister okay hey guys top 10
pretty pad videos here today we're
counting down the top 10 pretty pi
videos coming out you guys at number 1
youtube -
today is my first day at high school I
can't believe I'm finally here
I'm cutie pie my dance and did this mask
[Music]
[Applause]
I love YouTube high school it was like a
three-part series that I did making fun
of youtubers and youtube every fun
excuse me it's extremely [ __ ]
extremely stupid but that's sort of what
made it funny I think my favorite part
is the sound effect I did for when they
walk
oh boy that sure was a quick hi bear
mikono - [ __ ] idiot again and I
wanted it to become like YouTube High
School Musical so I started making songs
at the end of it but there is it in the
back door it is the back door
Lord
so better than everyday bro at least it
really just became too much effort
because people weren't watching it like
I know the uses and everything and like
I don't base all my decisions based on
use but the amount of effort these
videos took compared to like how little
views they got it didn't seem like
people really were into it so I didn't
really see a point spending all that
time like it would take me a day and a
half at least to make and I would like
do nothing else I'm not complaining I'm
just saying I really I'm really proud of
these videos because I really actually
try to make something a bit more but it
just wasn't worth it by moving on
command aspect never to get the [ __ ]
lover series yeah does anyone remember
these back in 2014 people love these I
think this is the first time I noticed
people were like well wait Peter pie
doesn't just make [ __ ] horror video
screaming at them he actually makes
funny stuff
I think these were those videos for a
lot of people they want please subscribe
to my new channel YouTube I think I'm
about to hit three sub soon please
subscribe and know so please don't hate
peace it was basically I I don't
remember what it was I just made up this
[ __ ] character and wrote a story
through the common gear time thanks for
size subs I think it was inspired when I
read hate comments based on a true story
here everyone never came
and come back to tell you all that I
need a big bunch of me and I want you
all to know that just because I don't do
good quickscopes and just because my
montage doesn't have many views that
doesn't mean I don't have really kind of
what it flows nicely
I don't know I their funny if you want
to watch them go right ahead alright -
coming up at top three everyone got
three pittypat this is so sick this is
so self-centered as anyone else on
YouTube ever made a top ten of your own
videos so [ __ ] [ __ ] Jesus Christ
PewDiePie was alright okay this one this
is my response video to my response
video it's kind of stupid when all the
Wall Street Journal stuff went down I
had to make some sort of video
addressing the situation seriously when
reality this is the video I wanted to
make basically just shedding on everyone
I thought it's solid it's it's
bulletproof I go through everything very
well I articulated my points in a way
where you can't really dispute it and I
really didn't want to upload this video
because I thought it would stir up more
drama in the media now nothing
say it's not true he has two hard-on for
the Nazi no ah that's the metric somatic
cell and not a single media outlet
posted about it I'm they'll take like my
update vlogs and make 20 articles like
hundreds of articles about but this
video me addressing the media directly
in a negative way that I think they
can't really argue against not a single
not a single article I'm not joking no
one posted about it I remember I posted
it before the weekend and I was legit
exhausted from all the drama from the
media and I was like [ __ ] I shouldn't
upload this video because it's just
gonna stir [ __ ] up nothing I was legit
amazed I was like how is this possible
that no one is addressing this and then
I was like oh yeah because it makes them
look bad don't get me wrong I don't
really care about all the stuff that
happened anymore I'm not trying to bring
up all drama but I like the video I
think it's a good video and I'm proud of
it coming up at number four everyone
virtual reality in public this video
with the [ __ ] pain in the ass to film
I'm wearing a wireless we are headset so
I'm ready I can jump around wherever I
want let's see what Wireless VR has to
offer the future let's go basically we
just went out in public and I was
pretending I was very wearing a VR
headset hilarious for Justin Cross
skateboarders over here
when you guys come on oh yeah they were
ignoring me so hard it was so awkward
and the end them [ __ ] walking into
the ocean afterward we're like how do we
end it shitty video I'll just walk into
the ocean we're so [ __ ] cold not
worth it it's not worth it at all I
remember I was like just breathe and
think of the mean I remember going like
oh man
good time this [ __ ] video it's not my
favorite but since I'm on the topic of
[ __ ] [ __ ] legit me falling here I got
a star for life okay Pokemon go it's
dangerous
any worth day don't do that [ __ ] [ __ ]
YouTube and [ __ ] a Pokemon girl
moving on top 5 everyone can this video
get one minute probably the easiest
video we've ever shot I like [ __ ]
smart myspace familiar look I just love
the pure ADHD driven content
it's so [ __ ] [ __ ] coming up at at
6:00 anyway Ted see why are we still
here catch you kids
just Duke and everyone every night I can
feel my leg my own
[Music]
nodding o'clock where will is it
[Applause]
[Music]
it's good it's good
coming up at six everyone my favorite
videos I only like this video for two
reasons number one this legit two second
segment ROI coke I pursue what the [ __ ]
does that mean out [ __ ]
[ __ ] hell and and of course Menasha
please hi I'm NASA bleep and I'm your
freestyle dance teacher not for everyone
I lost camp I would have to say my
response to sorta it's so I think it's
the first time I responded to another
youtuber like I get a lot of videos like
this but I never actually brought I like
I just ignore them but I'm like I [ __ ]
it this is so stupid I have to make a
response
entertaining millions of people and what
the [ __ ] are you doing
I still love to quote that it's just
such a good meme coming in at top 3 are
you born yet cuz it's about to get good
be named dick oh the great this is
this video legit we had no idea I owe
this video to Brad cuz like we didn't
know what the [ __ ] to film
Brad was like I'll save this video we'll
do this and they said this and I'm like
ok let's do it and I didn't think it
would work but their video came out
great
that's the Pokemon no that's that
Pokemon right there normal Toastmaster
Kokomo those a real person was not
[ __ ] oh my god oh my god
it Pokemon unreal and dog on reality
[Music]
it's my favorite ending of any of my
videos ever
I love Part 2 as well because legit I
was terrified I thought I was going to
die a jar it was such a Streamy day like
I I'm glad I wore the life vest because
otherwise I would not have jumping
through the [ __ ] water Emily
look up
I remember swimming I was just like well
I hope I make it to shore like we ended
up in such a different location that we
started it was so stupid my number one
favorite video it's not even up on my
channel anymore because it got flagged
for copyright
it's so [ __ ] [ __ ] I bought this
[ __ ] car I bought the cheapest car I
could possibly find just to make fun of
people that flash just to make fun of
youtubers that flash their car we shot
the video we didn't think it was funny
at all but it came out hilarious in the
Edit I still have the car those are my
top 10 what are your favorite pewdiepie
videos haha no no I have no there's no
one of them because they're all [ __ ]
thank you very much thanks for watching
this one I hope to make another top 10
favourite in the future thank you guys
so much and it's always sister fixer